Well, you always start with a, because you can get a
by looking at the case of x equals 0 and then b doesn't matter.
So if x equals 0, so it means you write over here, then y equals a
that falls us directly from this question because x equals 0.
So what's the y value over here? It's 1 so that means a is to be 1.
Now that we know this, you can look at b.
We know that if x = 4 then the expression on the right over here gets us a 2 in the y dimension.
We really know a is you can put the a in which gives us 4b+1=2. We bring 1 to the right side.
Therefore, 4b=1 and then we divided by 4, which means b equals to fourth or quarter
and 0.25 and 1 other correct answers here.
So now you understand about lines. Let's talk about linear regression.